There's a lot packed into Chilling
Adventures of Sabrina's 36 episodes.
Alongside her friends, family, and coven,
Sabrina faces new and ancient threats,
plus saves the world a few times.
Here's the entire timeline of Chilling
Adventures of Sabrina explained, from
pre-show history to the series finale.
Hundreds of years ago, a group of Scottish
witches fleeing persecution were taken by boat
to Greendale, Massachusetts, by Dorothea Putnam.
But these witches were no safer in Greendale,
and thirteen of them were hunted and
hanged by ancestors of Harvey Kinkle,
Sabrina's first boyfriend. The Greendale Thirteen
and their coven were the earliest incarnation of
the Church of Night, to which Sabrina's family,
the Spellmans, have belonged for generations.
In the first season of Chilling Adventures
of Sabrina, the Thirteen are summoned by the
demon Lilith to attack the town. This is the
only time Greendale's original witches are
actually present on screen, but their story
informs much of what happens in the Church
of Night and in Greendale, especially as Sabrina
starts learning more about how to use her magic.
When Sabrina Spellman is born, two things
happen: Her aunt Zelda forges her signature
in the Book of the Beast, effectively taking
away Sabrina's choice whether to sign when
she comes of age as a witch. Her aunt Hilda
also witnesses Sabrina's Christian baptism,
which is strictly forbidden by the
Church of Night. This leads to Hilda
being excommunicated from the Church. It also
causes friction between Sabrina and Zelda,
and complicates Sabrina's decision to
sign the Book of the Beast herself.
Sabrina's parents, Edward, a
warlock, and Diana, a mortal,
are killed in a plane crash
when Sabrina is very young.
"Your father and mother were flying to Italy.
Edward was giving a lecture at the Vatican
when their plane went down. Tragically."
Originally believed to be an accident, Sabrina
later learns their deaths were calculated by
Father Blackwood, who saw Edward's progressive
ideas as a threat to the Church of Night.
In the show's pilot, Sabrina's favorite teacher,
Mrs. Wardwell, provides shelter to a distressed
young girl she finds on the side of the road.
When she brings the girl to her remote cottage,
Mrs. Wardwell is slain by the girl, who
then assumes her appearance and identity.
It's revealed that the shapeshifter
girl is Lilith, a demon from Hell.
She's come to Greendale to manipulate Sabrina into
signing the Book of the Beast. Lilith believes
this will give her what she wants, which is a
shared reign over Hell with her beloved Lucifer.
Eventually, Lilith reveals her true identity to
Sabrina and the Spellman family and
pretends to be a mentor to Sabrina.
Sabrina turns sixteen on Halloween night.
Her boyfriend, Harvey, really wants her to
celebrate with him and their friends, Roz
and Theo. But Sabrina is expected to sign
the Book of the Beast and be fully initiated
in the Church of Night coven. She can't spend
her birthday with her friends, and she'll be
expected to leave the mortal world behind.
Her aunts allow her to go to Roz's Halloween
party, but she's expected in the woods before
midnight to sign her soul over to Satan. While
she's standing in front of the Book of the Beast,
Sabrina believes that signing her name is a
choice that will allow her to embrace her power
and freely perform magic as a full witch. When
she learns that she'll actually be at the Dark
Lord's beck and call, she panics and runs out of
the woods. The coven follows, but Sabrina's cousin
Ambrose prevents them from crossing the Spellman
property line, protecting Sabrina from harm.
When Lilith summons the Thirteen
to Greendale, it's part of a master
plan to force Sabrina to sign the Book of
the Beast. But by summoning the Thirteen,
Lilith puts Greendale and the Church of Night
at risk, which means Sabrina is the only one
who can defeat them and save everyone. Sabrina
can't do that without the full use of her magic,
which she can only acquire by
agreeing to sell her soul to Satan.
In the season 1 finale, Sabrina finally puts her
name in the book and becomes a full-blooded witch.
In Season 2, she starts using magic
more frequently and tells her friends
she's a witch. This causes some problems,
particularly in her relationship with Harvey.
Sabrina starts attending the Academy of Unseen
Arts more often than she attends Baxter High,
and she even starts dating
a warlock, Nick Scratch.
With help from Lilith and Nick, Lucifer
Morningstar returns to his human form at
the end of Season 2. He makes several
revelations which alter the course of
Sabrina's life and the show. Perhaps the
most important one is that Edward Spellman
isn't actually Sabrina's father — Lucifer is.
Sabrina is thus in line to become Queen of Hell,
and Lucifer needs her to rule alongside him
so they can remake Earth in Hell's image. He
also needs Sabrina to blow the Horn of Gabriel to
open the gates of Hell, which will allow the dark
aristocracy to attend her coronation on Earth.
Sabrina refuses, but Lucifer isn't concerned.
"You will blow Gabriel's horn at sundown
in the clearing where you signed my book."
Lilith, meanwhile, is furious about Lucifer's
betrayal, so she turns on him and begins working
with Sabrina to stop the Dark Lord's
plan. All Lilith wants is the throne,
and all Sabrina wants is to continue
being a mostly regular teenager.
With Lilith's help, Sabrina attempts to trap
and imprison Lucifer so he doesn't destroy
Earth. But they soon realize the only way to
trap Lucifer is to put him in a human body.
Nick, Sabrina's boyfriend, is the most powerful
conjurer and binder since Edward Spellman.
As an apology to Sabrina for initially
befriending her on the Dark Lord's behalf,
Nick volunteers to become the vessel
and keep Lucifer contained. This traps
him in Hell with Lucifer in his body, and he
suffers intense trauma from the experience.
Sabrina then abdicates the throne
and makes Lilith Queen of Hell,
which is all Lilith ever wanted. In
exchange, Lilith restores Sabrina's magic,
which she lost for defying Lucifer, and
resurrects the actual Mrs. Wardwell.
While Sabrina deals with Lucifer in Season
2, Prudence learns she's Father Blackwood's
biological daughter. Blackwood's multiple attempts
to return the Church of Night to its old ways end
with him being scolded and punished by Lucifer,
so he takes his infant twins and flees. Prudence
and Ambrose go on a worldwide hunt to find
her father. When they find him in Scotland,
they discover he's manipulated time
to age both himself and the twins up.
Blackwood then becomes a prisoner of the coven,
and Sabrina's aunt Zelda becomes the new High
Priestess. The coven then turns to Hecate for
power, leaving Lucifer behind completely. When
Sabrina frees Lucifer from Nick's body,
she imprisons him in Blackwood's body,
though he doesn't stay confined for long.
The hunt for Blackwood ultimately damages
Prudence's relationship with Ambrose, who
asked her not to seek vengeance on her father.
When the aristocracy of Hell decides
Lilith isn't a legitimate queen,
Sabrina has to take her rightful place on the
throne, all while balancing her life on Earth.
But the aristocracy also doesn't recognize
Sabrina as a legitimate heir to the throne.
They instead support Prince Caliban, a clay
demon formed from Hell. Caliban and Sabrina
compete for the throne in a series of challenges
known as the Unholy Regalia. This requires
them to go back in time, acquire certain holy
objects, battle monsters, and fight each other.
Caliban nearly wins by tricking Sabrina into
giving him the final object needed to claim the
throne. Sabrina then creates a time paradox when
she realizes her attention to the Holy Regalia has
doomed the world to end. With the paradox, she's
able to stop Caliban and become the Queen of Hell.
Shortly after Nick becomes Lucifer's vessel
and Sabrina gives Lilith the throne of Hell,
a group of Pagans arrives in Greendale. They
are determined to return the world to the
Old Ones, which means sacrificing
virgins to awaken the Green Man
and end the modern world. The
Pagans disguise themselves as
carnival performers and attempt to seduce
Sabrina's friends into being sacrificed.
In the end stages of the Pagans' plan, Sabrina
is too caught up in the Holy Regalia to realize
how desperately her friends need her help.
Before she figures out how to go back in time,
Sabrina gets trapped in Hell, and
the Pagans kill her friends. Luckily,
using a "time egg" recovered from Father
Blackwood in Scotland allows Sabrina to
stop the Pagans and save the world, though she
creates a new set of problems in the process.
"What am I?"
To prevent the Pagans from winning and
stop Caliban from becoming King of Hell,
Sabrina is forced to manipulate time. The
version of her that's trapped in clay in Hell
is awoken by a different version, who has
already fixed everything. This version of
Sabrina tells the trapped version that she
must close the time loop by returning to Hell
and trading places with her to stop the massive
ramifications. In classic Sabrina Spellman style,
she ignores this advice and instead decides that
life would be easier if there were two of her.
So Sabrina Spellman returns to Earth while Sabrina
Morningstar remains in Hell and is crowned queen.
Morningstar marries Cailban and contentedly rules
over Hell with Lucifer and Lilith, doing all of
the things Spellman didn't want to do. When
Ambrose discovers what his cousin has done,
he forbids her from ever being in the same place
as Sabrina Morningstar again. Sabrina Spellman
abides until she needs Morningstar's help,
which, you guessed it, causes major problems.
After he leaves the Church of Night, acts as a
vessel for Lucifer, and is then given the Mark
of Cain so he can't be killed, Faustus Blackwood
decides to unleash the Eldritch Terrors, gods so
ancient they haven't been seen in thousands
of years. Of course, they want to end the
world. This power play is spurred by Blackwood's
anger at the Spellmans, particularly Sabrina,
and he seems to think he'll somehow be spared
when the Eldritch Terrors destroy everything.
Sabrina and her family are able to beat back the
Eldritch Terrors at first, even when Blackwood
uses the Perverse to become Emperor of Greendale
and rewrite reality. However, stopping the most
powerful Terror, The Void, requires a powerful
witch or warlock to sacrifice themselves.
The Cosmic is the first Eldritch Horror not
to manifest in Greendale itself. Instead,
it begins to condense Hell, Earth, and Heaven
until they bleed together, which ultimately
leads to chaos. An angel, Metatron, then arrives
in Greendale and tells the coven that this chaos
is the result of there being two Sabrinas. Their
continued existence has created a parallel cosmos,
which is being pulled toward Earth. To stop
the inevitable collision and The Cosmic,
one of the Sabrinas must be
sent to an alternate Earth.
Sabrinas Spellman and Morningstar both have lives
on Earth, so they decide that the fairest way to
determine who stays and who goes is to play
Rock, Paper, Scissors. Morningstar loses, so
she's sent away. On the alternate Earth, she's an
actor playing herself in a TV sitcom of her life,
surrounded by her family and friends who are also
playing versions of themselves. But The Endless,
in the form of an animatronic Salem, has
turned this realm into a never-ending sitcom
for its own amusement. Like
the other Eldritch Terrors,
The Endless is working for The Void. Sabrina
Morningstar realizes the problem and returns
to the main Earth to warn Sabrina Spellman,
then dies from the trip through realms.
In a last-ditch effort to
keep Lucifer from killing her,
Lilith convinces Blackwood to sleep with her while
he's Lucifer's vessel so she'll become pregnant
with Lucifer's child. Lilith intends to use
her child as a means of becoming Queen of Hell.
She schemes that her child can kill Lucifer
to claim the throne to make her Queen Mother.
When Lucifer tries to take the child from her,
she kills the boy herself and makes a meal of him.
Lilith's final act in the series finale is
to stab Lucifer, drink his celestial blood,
and then banish him to wander the mortal
world so she can rule Hell in peace.
Throughout Chilling Adventures of Sabrina
season 4, the coven works with hedge witches
to try and stop the Eldritch Terrors. They
quickly realize they're out of their depth,
so Sabrina Spellman tries to solve
the problem by trapping The Void in
Pandora's Box. That unfortunately
requires her to sacrifice herself.
Her family isn't willing to let her go, so they
summon her spirit back to Sabrina Morningstar's
body, which creates a war between Hell and
Earth. Spellman realizes she's taken part of the
Void into herself when she starts disappearing
random objects, Caliban, and Harvey's father.
She fears hurting her loved ones, so she flees
to the Mountains of Madness where Faustus
Blackwood claims he can train her to contain
The Void. Blackwood secretly plans to rip The
Void from Sabrina's body to claim the power for
himself. Sabrina's friends attempt to save her,
but returning the people Sabrina accidentally
disappeared requires Zelda to cut Sabrina open
and drain The Void from her body. This opens a
gateway, allowing Ambrose and Harvey to put the
Eldritch Terrors they've trapped inside The Void,
and retrieve the people. Once everyone has been
returned from The Void, Nick uses Pandora's Box
to trap The Void forever. Sabrina doesn't survive,
and her family mourns both her and
Sabrina Morningstar back in Greendale.
Chilling Adventures of Sabrina ends with
Sabrina and Nick in the Sweet Hereafter,
which is a much friendlier afterlife than any
others that have been shown in the series.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.